hello and welcome to this video
mrs. Cuomo's and he plays some knight c6
stuff so we transpose into in English I
wanted to do f5 but this simply set in
working I mean I can go in 3 and D for
for certain
let me just keep a good structure it
looks a little bit like Indians oh
somehow with a like black and black has
taken one move for this okay it's not
even that bad
[Music]
ninety-four now makes sense trade the
bishop
Marva ok IM black can also play other
moves in 94 looks like the most logical
choice down you know yeah i turned out
really solid fun i didn't really show
that Bishop c5 strange which it is it
really is but here black is not not in
bad shape so what to do maybe just
specially tuned
yeah I wonder if before was something
that he wants to do gaining space yeah
yeah I just come with me okay
I'm not sure about this kind of thing
the 19 million he can improve the light
and it's a move I completely expected to
happen but is he really opening up the G
file for me no1 he doesn't he isn't
really just this stop everything here no
that's not a good people hey no please
not Bishop f3 premier
yeah this looks nicer I've got a 5v5
coming and now he cannot go to e5 it was
the main point of playing F form this
does not look all that grade d5 and F
group G one Bishop can come to h5 so
he's actually self pinning him spinning
going into his helping is what I'm
trying to say okay so I'm threatening
Luke checks at five and he cannot take
that rook what is your move
know that something has no move Knight
h6 them maybe to cover a fire for the
time being but sorta believe that should
be a fully satisfactory defense if I go
look aged five now what's going on down
I mean I began just this increase the
pressure book age five is also a threat
now
yeah well he cannot take this
hmm yes it does not have many moves that
you can play really how to tell them to
do this
I don't see a forced way to do it
I can't believe just wait for a moment
here I don't I don't see when I mean you
cannot move any of us we can only move
the Queen around here nothing else can
be moved I would get three ha ha I'm
actually doing something with rubgy 3
that I didn't understand
Oh cook age 3 I'm threatening this cook
there could be an eat soup Tonya look
after who gets recreated but what what
is this next move black resigns it is
terrible I cannot move her but I don't I
don't see a full swing really and [ __ ]
fish cooks like plus 2 it doesn't seem
to find a knockout I mean give him
people lose on time I'm to blame running
out 2000 moves I thought this man I
worked g7 is also keeping it going hey
looks that way I cannot move him but
it's not falling apart
ok yeah I think um I think the g5 and
then this is g5 you can probably play
but like here T King doesn't work I mean
really doesn't look that just opens up a
file for me yeah and here you see that
and I'm winning winning engine-wise
yeah book age six Stooges suggested by
the comp yeah this this book everyone
will be able have played I mean you can
close it down but I felt like here I
should be a bit better on the queenside
nothing much but it isn't the better the
good thing is that this f4 point is
making sure that the night is not really
getting anywhere but like is still very
solid so after after it opened up that
was pretty awful well I can barely move
at the end he would have lost one time
but there doesn't seem to be a forced
winner as the engine now suggests okay
guys thanks for watching